today we're talking about the power
vignettes and after effects let's get
[Music]
started hey everyone my name is cam with
motion science and today we are talking
about the power of vignettes and after
effects now you may think of vignettes
as a simple thing but really a vignette
helps to create framing uh around our
scene and it can bring attention to
certain areas of the scene so let's jump
into after effects and I'll show you
what I mean so here we are in After
Effects the first way to apply a
vignette is to go to effect and go down
to stylize and we've got something here
called CC vignette and I click and you
can see it's immediately applied here if
I turn it off and on you can see how
it's being applied to the edges now I
like to play around with the different
variables here so the amount I'm going
turn it up slightly uh the angle view
you can see what it's doing there uh pin
highlights I typically will turn these
up
uh but these are just a few parameters
you can play around with to get some
different looks now we can take this a
step further by putting our Center Point
here on the car right so if I bring the
center point over to the left of the
screen it's obviously highlighting this
part of the screen over here it's
highlighting more of the right side so
if we follow the car we can set a key
frame here for the
center and go to the end of our timeline
and bring it over here and if I preview
this it's a very subtle effect but it
brings attention to the car
driving down the road now I could also
increase the amount here so we can
really
see the edges darkening up and it's a
lot more attention on the car driving
down the road so this is a simple way to
apply vignette now I can take this a
step further by turning off and yet
we're back to our original plate go to
layer new solid and I can create a dark
blue Sol like we see here and this is
just a matter of me samp Ling the road
right in here clicking okay and now we
have a solid above it now I can double
click on the circular mask and that's a
basic mask I can go to the mask click
inverted and hit f for feather and turn
that feather up like this and now you
can see instead of just black edges we
have these blue soft edges now I can
take this a step further by taking that
mask and I can double click it and
rotate it to follow the road so like we
did with the vignette
effect and kind of bring it over here I
can turn down the transparency as well
vignettes are typically a pretty subtle
effect that we apply but you can see now
we've got kind of this bluish tent
that's happening as it's following the
road now I can take this a step further
Again by hitting M for mask setting a
key frame here at the beginning going to
the end the
timeline and rotating it more
follow the road like we see here and
again it's pulling attention to the car
I can take this a step further by
changing the transfer mode from normal
to something like hardlight and we can
adjust the transparency again I can
crank it up I can crank it down and what
this is doing is creating more contrasts
on the sides as we can see here so again
it's not something that's really in your
face that's a big noticeable change but
if I turn it off you can see there how
we're bringing the attention into the
screen now I can take this in a totally
different direction by changing this
dark solid to a bright solid so if we go
up here to
White click that click okay and then
turn down the transparency here now it
has a bunch of different look to
it so again with and without hey so
really quickly I want to let you know
I've got a free pdf guide for you to
download it's the complete guide to
organic motion design it's absolutely
free motion science .
tvguide it's my tips and tricks around
ways that I get cinematic looks in
motion design organic cinematic looks
like you seen a lot of my work so
definitely go check it out after this
video motion science.
tvguide so let's take a look at another
way you could approach this drag this
footage down here and we'll make another
new
solid and we'll change the color to this
blue color click okay now instead of
just creating a circular mask I take the
pin tool and I can draw a mask here so
I'm putting emphasis on the corners
making it not so
perfect and we'll hit M for mask we'll
click inverted f for feather and we'll
feather this up something like that and
then we'll set this one to soft
light and you can see again with and
without it just creates more contrast on
the edges of the frame drawing our
attention drawing the viewers attention
into the center of the frame also show
you how this looks with some additional
footage here so I'll turn the mask off
and on again we're getting this nice
kind of candy cotton candy look to the
sides of the frame drawing our attention
into the center of the frame and let's
take this one more step further let's
grab this footage
here and we're going to go ahead and
bring this solid over the top so again
you can see how nice that looks right
it's bringing the attention into the
center of the frame but another way we
could also approach this is by adding a
new adjustment layer so we'll go to
layer new adjustment layer and we're
going to drop this underneath the color
and we'll select M for mask copy that
mask and apply it to the adjustment
layer and to that adjustment layer we're
going to go to effect and you can use
any blur here I like to use the camera
lens blur personally and we'll crank
this up to about 15 and you can see
now we've got these really soft edges so
footage by
itself blurred
edges and colored edges I could actually
even take this mask bring it in just a
little bit for the
blur shrink it in just a little bit
maybe bring the top of it up but we are
heavily blurring the edges so again
we're bringing attention into the center
of the frame to the monolith here and
that my friends is a few easy ways to
use vignette to really draw attention to
the center of your composition to add
visual interest to your composition as
always thanks for being here today and I
will see you in the next
[Music]
video